this week's videos are sponsored by
expressvpn more on them after the
reaction
people what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation we are going to
watch two episodes of Scott Pilgrim
today episode three and four we're going
to start double uping for reasons that
are pretty obvious ladies and Gentlemen
please go ahead and leave a like on this
video that would mean the world also be
sure subscribe click the notification
Bell to get notified when our reactions
for the next episodes of Scott Pilgrim
reactions up here on the Chanel thank
you to prep for helping us edit down
these highlights as always a big thank
you saw a good amount of you guys did
join our patreon page for Scott Pilgrim
fing through at and watch alongs where
you single with your own copy so we
cover several things over there
exclusively with highlights and watch
alongs included guys let's get into
[Music]
it that's a flower like Ramona Flowers
and a fly buzzing by to Signal symbolize
death Young Neil's
bedroom oh young Neil's a screenplay
Rider at my roommate's band maid's
funeral thinking what if I can die and
just when I found out I'm a
copile anyways that's why I'm busy
writing this movie so don't bother
calling the late inspiration ends
becoming a writer oh yeah he's got the
fight club
poster oh inspiration struck oh scream
[Music]
I've written
nothing and it's
autobiographical O Beautiful
shot mad
Madness oh AI chaty BT in physical
manifestation that's what the robots
want my sleep paralysis de
demon wow if my sleeper alysis demon
could write me a
screenplay written by Young Neil the
hell is going on in this show I wrote a
feature like screenplay on my
sleep I'm a
[Music]
screenwriter F it's all it takes your
Prodigy man just takes one just takes
the right software you know it's how
good final draft
is oh die again the morning phase is
passed
sounds
oo like a flame it's always that same
look yeah it's always that umbre thing
Bona rents a video I'll be returning
some videotapes you changed your hair
what's up Ramona nothing major just
somebody kidnapped Scott Pilgrim and
faked his death you're [__]
joking bringing back the censoring tell
me everything last night in my dreams I
saw Scott's Subspace Highway they do
communicate in this like dream plane oh
no that astral I think it means he's
alive he's a force ghost so I went back
to the rocket to look at the security
footage of what we thought was Scott's
death
cops couldn't figure this out
nope
[Music]
whoa someone grabbed him and pulled him
into a portal it took you going through
the security camera footage to nobody
had a right vantage point to see that I
knew it was too good to be
true your sugar daddy days are over for
him absolutely for others we'll see the
future is a mystery oh only Ramona seems
sad that Scott's missing don't tell me
you're going to try to find him I think
I have to detective flowers you went on
one date how good could it have been
honestly great your date with Scott
[Music]
pilgram a I thought you could give me a
quick rundown of the major characters in
Scott's life more like major suspects
yeah there's Steven Stills my ex the
singer in the band he's a mess I don't
remember them used they used to date I
don't remember that there's Steven's
roommate Young Neil he's kind of
sheltered and he's only 19 but don't let
that fool you he's a copile what about
Envy Adams Envy Adams pulled Scott's
heart out of his F and stomped all over
it with her patent leather combat boots
I saw her do her thing at the funeral
she's even hotter in person
true are we sure they dided you're
obviously not the only one with
questionable taste Ramona now having
that film new warm fatal quality in the
first episode suddenly makes sense you
know who you should talk to his other
ex what is sex bomb without Scott that
looks good what if we find a new bass
player and they make us worse the odds
are they'd make us better because we
probably sucked there's always Scott's
understudy knives which join how long
have you been playing the drums a long
time since I was 14 drumming's a great
outlet for my emotions what a that
random realistic far
[Music]
away there you go double
down oh hell yeah getting in the zone oh
hell
yeah take L to care with the
instrumentation
animation look at you jamming together
what a beautiful Lucid experience you
could be one of those bands where it's
just two people and one of them plays
bass someone plays drums and sings it's
perfect Death from Above 1970
knives wow you're
better how long have you been playing
bass what time is it 400 p.m. then 4
hours I'm late for work you ever thought
about collaborating with a seasoned
songwriter
[Music]
uh uh-oh what do you know they used to
date right and Scott used to date her
the drummer in the movie at least I
think that was in her first episode
Chiron after to refresh funny thought
maybe he faked his own death to get out
of paying his late
fees he's not dead you've been using
using Scott's unconscious Dreamscape to
deliver DVDs quicker Julie said you knew
him the longest when did you meet you
told me you were good at drawing real
backstory draw me a
sheep that's the worst sheep I've ever
seen sheep is
excellent oh no did she still love him
there was this one time I was kidnapped
by a rival school and Scott had to fight
through an entire Army of teen jerks and
their leader Simon Lee to rescue me S
that's a romantic memory how romantic
can a memory be if things ended terribly
I love how he's got this whole backstory
of being this season fighter it's like
badass yeah why does this always happen
to me I don't know maybe you could ask
one of your seven evil exes this is
unexpected well you better get better at
expecting you're Roxy RoR Ramona's
fourth evil X is Ramona gonna fight oh I
guess maybe she has to I'm here for us
Ramona first in line to win your heart
because I have something the others
never will oh emotional intelligence cuz
a woman man you're just impossible to
talk to you want to talk about feelings
start talking oh damn they're really
hashing this out let's fight about
himor flowers she's so
reluctant are we really doing this again
wa again what the hell nice with the
Mallet I respect the
Mallet whoa damn oh there's some sexual
tension here doing the Black Widow
thing oh this is how DVD stores came to
be
destroyed come
on wa how f on
oo movie hopping into all these other
typs of films that's so
cool it really looks like the Matrix or
something that's
cheap Oh Be Kind Rewind
took a lot of slashes for that remote
control yes do the whole video store did
Young Neil WR this fight sequence
[Music]
I kill her
yes
[Music]
o they're just working [__]
out oh super old school animation I'm
sorry for what
for leaving the way I did set her
free interesting using genra to express
the emotional state of
him now it's a silent film I was too
afraid to face you you made me feel like
nothing all I wanted was for you to see
me this has like an Especial dubbed look
but that doesn't mean I'm going to let
you
win save her
Ramona oh damn sounded
painful or turn off the movie yeah what
are the rules switch to a kid's
movie
whoa ouch ah oh man there's so much
Cinema
here a as far as I'm concerned you won
that's what it's all about we were
pretty immature weren't we Ramona
fighting her own ax how woke really
takes control of the narrative from our
man who needs character
boost you were really kicking my ass oh
my God they made a men saying that
should we kiss uh-uh he's dead Ramona
it's complicated I've got to find him
first I'd like to be your friend with
benefits what about you oh I'm
not oh maybe try it
out wow go
for no saliva and everything everybody
needs closure that's why they call it
closure now you're one step closer to
the dumb boy of your dreams and you
buried the hatchet with an ex oh we're
watching Ramona's story I guess so I
guess it's Ramona Flowers takes off
don't tell me I'm going to have to do
this with all seven of them we are
watching Ramona's story Scott Pilgrim
takes off so Ramona can deal with this
[__] herself she's going to deal with
her ex's directly how woke dude it's too
woke for me is he evil enough to kidnap
a dude and fake his yeah only one way to
find
out
uhoh no account
video the robot what a wild show some
bold storytelling swings here G Eng
Graves
Gman you don't remember me oh GID
engraves wasn't my birth name it was an
identity I created when I moved to New
York City I left my past behind and
leveled up we're going to strip him down
you knew me by another name sultry Suave
Gordon Gordon Goose from North Bay
Ontario Gordon go I've lost everything
my Empire is gone my billionaire friends
have shunned me even my millionaire
friends have turned their
[Laughter]
backs you still got those thousand dares
Gordon inv vitamin get your butt in here
a
[Music]
it's like watching an alternate universe
Wolf Teen Scott it's about time there's
one thing I've been complaining about is
they haven't met their Finn wolfart
quoti John the next episode's about to
start oh 3 two 1
go
who I have I have the same same thing
but with
me shades on and all oh another day on
God's green baby oil
Earth wow that is very rich Glendale
California he lives at the
Americana oh my God his decks are so
righteous got a two
tattoo whatever
whatever went down to the beach and S Ki
she was all like and I'm like what
whatever I haven't heard this song in a
decade or
more how cool
Wicked Lucas Lee's Pro
Skater I think he is skating through the
American it's at least based on it
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah well done
nachos oh and this bar is totally
nearby that's my agent fellas agent chiz
oh oh it's El Coyote this town's on the
verge of saying see you later boy you
are one mistake away from movie jail
Skater Boy good thing I've got to get
out a jail free card my ACT is acting
you want goody two shoes buy them at a
shoe store well that's just the sort of
thing that's made you nigh unemployable
breaking the dimensions your flight to
Toronto departs in 4 hours you must be
professional at every opportunity or the
stardom you love so much will slip
through your grasp what an interesting
inverse you love so giving them each
some kind of
struggle
whatever the First the
movie
Whatever shouts out to Le
Lynch the the movie has is Cinema with a
big spin on video games and Anime and
then the one that has the visual of an
anime and and video games is doing a lot
of Riff on Cinema yeah it's like what
they did with Brie Larson not singing
the song instead of Emily Haynes from
last time it was really
funny they
die this is how every next episode
begins
[Music]
green and lighter
green do
look poison
ivy T oh Toronto wood Toronto wood this
the set of the Lucas Lee movie without
explicit permission Lucas eel Lucas Lee
is here of course he's here what do you
think our job is do you know his time F
Nick Frost
yeah as cops perfect I recognized Nick
Frost first actually yeah same the same
beat of that must be
S he's already working on a
stud oh it's look as starring in his
movie I'm just the writer of this movie
uh-huh you wrote a movie Yes you wrote a
Lucas Lee
movie oh no
what oh
no weird why is Envy Adams dressed like
me she's playing Ramona Flowers What's
the title of this movie Scott Pilgrim
takes off Scott Pilgrim's precious
little life
you wrote an entire script about a world
where Scott Pilgrim won the fight with
Matthew Patel
basically
whoa cookie
meta oh great Audrey 2 Godzilla did you
know in the US these are called Mario
Karts that can't be true nuns nuns like
a raptor oh well they're called that
pretty sure that's not true either oh my
God now just an amalgamation
ET if there's one story where makes
sense to do a flip on who you're going
to focus on it would be the one who's
like directly connected to the X's yeah
totally
Crush
yes we need to talk about Scott Pilgrim
I'm Scott Pilgrim no the real Scott
Pilgrim you saying I'm a fake Scott
Pilgrim
we're about to shoot my first scene got
to give the people what they want Crank
That Lucas Lee charm to
[Laughter]
11 are you hitting on me maybe I am and
maybe I
[Laughter]
am oh my
Lord oh golly
[Laughter]
yeah careful
careful I had a dream about that girl
again I care even less now hey how was
that uh gay enough any notes how about
you build a time machine go back in time
and never audition for this part in the
first
place who has the nerve to share his
opinions on the set of my film yes me
what your
name I'm well as
Wells method wow well as Wells is just
so like
method wow how'd you know exactly what
Scott and I said in bed that morning the
creative process is a mystery Scott was
the one I hear Mr Lee is already balls
deep in a sweaty affair with someone on
the production Envy Adams gossip on who
the lucky lady might be not the mystery
I'm trying to solve I'm reading the
script I'm busy come back later I'm not
falling for that I know you have a girl
in there can we just get this over with
get what over with
oh he's actually reading the script did
you know I'm in this yeah you're the
lead no there's a Lucas Lee character
and Scott tricks him into grinding to
death I'd never fall for that what kind
of idiot would write this yeah that's
right
who who put that garbage can
there that's his coffee Young Neil may
not be the brightest but he has a vivid
imagination the ending is unrealistic
the Ramona Flowers I know would be on to
the next one that was a long time ago
how interesting Scott's not dead someone
wants us to think he is who that's what
I'm trying to find out you think I'd
kidnap some Canadian loser and fake his
death maybe you want a quest to find a
guy who was dating a high schooler I'd
never do anything that stupid if I did
my career would be over Lucas
H what my God what the the actor playing
Scott Pilgrim is dating an actress
playing a high schooler oh God you're
dating a 17-year-old she's 31 in real
life act's playing high
schooler an earthquake in Toronto no
something worse oh got to work
together
[Laughter]
paparazzi
cool way to do this lighting trick
Lucas
yes M twist
him we have you surrounded after scum
show
yourself it's like an Animaniac
bit they're actually
filming whatever
Luc Le verus the hell
yeah
nice oh now we're in game
[Music]
mode
whoa
great oh they're like a
smoke yep wck those bonus points of
combos
[Music]
mayy
damn
what a Jurassic Park skeleton Jurassic
Le oh
jaw oh
damn I love this this is
brilliant feels like an old school
arcade
game oh my God God yes bonus
points
sweet take photos of your demise
yes no they can skate is there m
multiples of them or one that's super
fast oh that fishy even got Escape video
culture in
[Music]
there some old school anime
[__]
[Music]
wow that's agent yeah probably yeah
that's what it looked like need an
assist why would you help me what do you
mean I always helped you
oh oh my
God she taught him how to grind down the
pole
yes she was the skate
[Music]
coach damn Ramona you broke so many
hearts until you left me with nothing
but a broken
heart all the healing You' done until
that point he became who he is because
of her was the day I decided who I was
going to be the best skater the highest
paid actor the biggest star all clear I
just got off with my agent I'm off the
movie and she's dumping me as a client
o maybe this will all blow over nah
they're already testing new actors to
play Scott by tomorrow morning someone
else will be Cas in the role of the guy
you like more than me and I'll be back
to being nobody I wonder who it'll be
the Brandon Ralph one
still think I kidnapped the real scottt
Pilgrim no I don't see you as a
kidnapping guy or a portal guy because I
didn't that was the night of the Teen
sorcerer Ford premere in
La
whoa this kid lands on his feet
[Music]
[Applause]
though
portal all this vegan vegan Powers vegan
portals vegan portals and I'm here to
audition for the part of Scott Pilgrim
well good luck watch out guys vegan
coming
[Music]
through as it should
be
yes we nailed it yeah
buddy Brandon Ralph up next let's go
let's go vegan
police wow wow wow wow wow wow that was
pretty great continuously you know
what's fun we're watching this on
Netflix oh is it on Netflix it's on
Netflix and I I also know that if you're
able to change your location How would
how would you do that you could I mean
first I should probably tell you that if
you change your location you don't just
go how would you do that let me finish
what you want to do is then you change
yeah yeah wow terrible I'm just so
excited play the ad big thanks to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video a
real game changer I've been using for
years that's right years so whenever
they want to work with us it's an
instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum showing
down my internet and contacted me due to
a suspecting hacking attempt and funny
enough I realized I hadn't actually
activated my Express Fe on my new laptop
that I got a couple of months ago so I
was paying the consequences having faced
a serious hacking issue on YouTube a
couple years ago that made expressvpn my
go-to for both security and freedom I
mean it and yes what you've heard is
true believe me this channel knows you
can use expressvpn to watch movies and
shows on Netflix that are not available
in your country this means accessing a
vast rate of content of over a 100
countries like a global Cinema your
fingertips it's super easy open
expressvpn switch locations refresh the
browser and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korean Netflix ULU
BBC I player YouTube or more expressvpn
has you covered and it's incredibly fast
ensuring no buffering or lack for smooth
HD streaming it's versatile too working
on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means
you can enjoy your favorite shows at
anywhere any screen protect and elevate
your internet experience so if you want
to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and
you can get an extra 3 months of
expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com reject to learn more
thank you again well John did you love
it I did I've been loving this
consistently Are People obset Are People
annoyed I've been seeing the word woke
go around I didn't know why I didn't
know why it was going around and then it
dawned on me in the LA in the Roxy
episode of okay I get it because this is
rona's Adventure now yeah and Scott's
probably not going to return until like
the end of the series unless they
subvert our expect yet again I mean I
can understand though that that is a big
ask of people yeah the title character
is gone it is I'm not UPS I'm not upset
it is it is a like oh what a shift be
when you go from your first episode to
really riffing off of the movie to then
go just kidding pull pulling the rug out
underneath you we
are significantly subverting
expectations and it would be a waste of
time if they were just doing an
adaptation of the movie yeah so to do a
a different perspective on it is a
really interesting thing cuz it's more
than just pulling back the curtain more
it's more than just getting some
backstory on on characters we didn't get
before it completely changes the way the
plot unfolds it's like it's still the
the setup of Ramona having to deal with
uh her seven exes but now there's a
different purpose a different Drive
behind it and and it's a it becomes this
commentary to on a lot of things that is
very very meta in its own way while
staying very true to the execution of
everything it's aiming to evoke in terms
of its animation period and style like
it really does feel like they're not
trying to be this era it it feels like
it is this era yeah
um that just happens to have these
modern day settings to it a reasonably
modern day like a few years ago you know
yeah yeah yeah uh which which I think is
really cool and then it's got more of a
a sweetness and more of a closure to it
versus I just got to like fight these
people and win it's a completely
different kind of plot because Ramona
has to uh find resolve with that that's
usually the solution with it while
leading to some fun video game fight
levels with the Roxy and the different
genre hopping around like a Looney Tunes
episode and then with um Lucas Lee
feeling like an arcade game you know
like Ninja Turtles or Simpsons with
fighting people with skateboards totally
yeah so uh but it's still fun and it's
different it's a different ask and and I
it it is a I can see why it could
there's an audience that could be uh
challenged to get on board for for for
it but I I personally like it I do I'm
looking forward to seeing how How It
ultimately concludes but it would feel
like a waste of time if it was just a
Nostalgia it would just feel yeah a fun
excuse to get everybody back together
whereas this is like oh it's riding on
more than it's not resting on that alone
yeah yeah it's not there's an actual
exploration of of different things to do
do while being able to actually give us
completely different scenes and and
locations to deal with
while being while being like funny and
and taking the piss out of itself yeah
like it doesn't it's very expressive but
it doesn't feel like pretentiously deep
in any way no I I haven't read much at
all about this just to keep the
experience fresh but I did see a small
quote from Brian Leo Mali kind of
addressing like you know I wanted to go
back to this and not just you know
regurgitate it or you know do the whole
like like these things I wanted to come
back and kind of do I wanted to reflect
on it so many years
later through kind of through what this
is and you know make it worthwhile in
that way and I can kind of see that
because this has like a it's like a
tenderness of maturity almost because
like Scott M the way Scott's story is
pitched it's very much like you know a
boy you know becoming less of a boy and
this is yeah pitching it I don't know it
makes a whole lot more like truly uh
qualitative emotional sense to have
Ramona being the one who is in this
position and so it's like yeah she's
like clearing all this weight before at
least as it feels right now the goal is
kind of clear all this weight on the
road to getting Scott back and like you
know obviously it's not in her mind as
structured as like I got to see them all
you know in finding them all she'll you
know yeah release all this probably
right before finding him and I think
that's a really lovely thing to do and
it makes sense it gives her character I
don't know just like yeah more autonomy
and it makes her less of a device you
know like a you know manic pixie dream
girl type like I like the character a
lot in the movie but I I am imagining
you know what you could there's just a
much more boyish and masculine
perspective through that whereas this is
a bit more varied and I think
authentically so and I like the way that
they characterize it and to me it's it's
like yeah it's it's it is a big ask
because it's the title character and so
much is about his journey love Michael
Sarah in that part but I think they're
fortunate in the fact that so much of
this is a an ensemble and B so much
about the voice of its World more so
than just the specific character
necessarily and I mean there are many
many Scott Pilgrim books and and stories
I I from what I understand beyond the
main one we know from the movie so like
you know I would have to imagine that if
this season is successful enough like I
Scott would you know be in a more
fleshed out story if they were to
continue or whatever but for what this
is here and now uh yeah like I I I think
it's really fun and I haven't
been it's not like they do a ton to make
him like super present but it's all
about finding him and what happened to
him and they're doing stuff with his
story so it still feels like Scott is
represented even though he's not like on
on screen well some there there are
parts of the movie too that felt
like you know the there there this kind
of self-awareness
commentary that you often see in in like
certain comedies you see in a lot of
Marvel things that if like oh if they
just say it that immediately alleviates
it when shading you yeah yeah but that
it that level of
self-awareness it's like just because
you pointed it out doesn't mean it's
it's eliminated the issue yeah and I
think with the Scott Pilgrim movie there
were aspects as well I love it there
were aspects that the show itself seems
to really be acknowledging yeah of you
know yeah they weren't the best fleshed
out moments of it and and and I so I
like the self-aware commentary on that
while still be you know what this kind
of reminds you have you seen the movie
Brick yeah kind of reminds me of brick
yeah a little bit that yeah yeah not not
teen sleuth but yeah like sort of
amateur youth youth sleuth yeah young
adult film new war that seems to be a
movie junkie kind of thing yeah yeah
yeah with a lot of genre splicing
happening um but but in it's like
animated medium yeah I I like it it's
fun
and yeah I mean I'm overall I'm I'm
satisfied as I like the I like how it
doesn't also paint Ramona as you get
these like tonal insights into parts of
their with the flashback stuff that's
not really laying it down thick on what
made the relationship great it's just
how they that somberness when looking
upon the memories of their last moments
together with Roxy with Lucas Lee and a
couple brief fleeting glimpses of like
what the you know what it was like good
what the romance was like yeah yeah but
it's also acknowledging a lot of the uh
attachment issues that Ramona herself
even runs into and I I even like the the
again the self-awareness of Ramona being
like yeah no Scott's not my boyfriend
and we only went on one date but it sure
was a memory for me and it's like as
she's on revisiting these
memories of people who couldn't let her
go she can't let Scott go yeah you know
so there is a cool mirror effect there
yeah they're doing a lot of nice yeah
mirroring and complimenting of things
and uh and too I I just you know I think
I like that thing that you pointed out
that this being I like that too yeah
then you know what I'm going to say and
we don't I don't even need to like hear
it honestly I know exactly what you're
getting at CU I don't only said one
thing so I just I could just assume was
that one thing that one comment when you
were like you laughed and yeah it was I
too
yeah say it again you said the thing
about the movie having yeah the movie
being you know bringing all this to live
action has so many flourishes and ODS to
the styles of animation and whatnot and
I think the way they've taken that baton
and run with it is very fun and as you
you know expound it it it it flips that
and and does a lot of film styling and
video game styling on top of this
animated medium and so like I did say
having the prospect that each set of x's
will bring their own kind of thing is
nice and and that was true of the movie
too but here yeah you had that Montage
of like all the different kinds of
movies with all the different color
grading and film grains and stuff like
that and you have the whole like
spending time like it really reminded me
of Animaniacs in the second episode just
spending time on the lot and all the
gags and Young Neil becoming a scream
screen writer I like young NE and then
when Lucas Lee has his fight like
there's so many skateboard game
Traditions thrown in there it's like you
have the ones that are like oh some kind
of downhill slalom thing or the ones
that are yeah like The Simpsons or
skater die or or you know even jouster
or stuff like that where yeah you were
doing like skateboard melee stuff and
yeah and uh yeah like they managed to
smoosh all those things together in one
sequence sure that you know kind of
exists as its own on on just like a I
don't know it's a great little you know
animated interlude but it's yeah clearly
kind of I don't know very very
encompassing of much time in culture in
a in a fun and impressive way in ways
that that you can enjoy without having
all the touchstones but if you've got
some or most of them then it's even more
rich and I think that's kind of a nice
thing about this too is like there are a
broad array of random different little
Easter egg things that are just like I
don't know I think it's just because
it's a a back lot and it's not like one
specific franchise it feels a little
less lurid it feels a little more fun
when you can just be like oh here's a
bunch of [__] that would be on a back
ladder let's do one of those gags where
you're on a mural or a you know mat
painting and then you know someone
bursts through it and we pull out and we
find out that we're still on the back
lot like yeah yeah there's so many great
like film flourishes and I just adore
that within one episode Young Neil is a
full on screen
writer full a Hollywood dream yeah
totally and we got our assignment wres
it overnight I'm a writer I'm a writer
and S neck Frost without Edgar right
actually directing we're never going to
get that Reunion yeah no more cornettos
all righty guys well do you think Scott
Pilgrim takes off as a woke garbage that
Hollywood is making Jam thought down
below uh be sure to subscribe leave a
like and thank you to express mepn and
we will chitchat with everyone here
relatively soon thank you for being here
with us on this journey
[Music]
by